What did her disciples do to our country? They
killed a lot of innocent people.If it weren't for the witches, the
demons would never have been able to take it away.Maybe
that's right.If it wasn't for magic, it would be snow.What
witch could
kill a body like that?  You all did the same thing,
didn't you? There was a witch hunt 10 years ago, and
why is there so much blood being spilled today? Just because they've acquired
science and no longer needs us, there's
no need to kill
witches.  People were just friends, Yamato-san,
why don't we end this conflict? First, I
want you to order the soldiers to retreat. Don't play around with them. They'll definitely obey. These feelings
[Music]
are funny. [
Music]
I am the great Lydia
[Music] I
am the head of the Imperial Security Bureau Yamato Joseki. I
lost to this kind of magic. [Music
]
I will follow you.
[Applause]
[Music] I
have no choice but to take revenge.